les nervis de hashtag bah tant mieux a
conduit à beaucoup de vos réactions et
beaucoup de critiques très intéressante
qui pour beaucoup vient du fait que j'ai
surtout manqué beaucoup de clarté dans
la vidéo précédente
en parlant notamment du cas des voix il
supprima schiste je pense que c'est un
peu dévié la discussion vers d'autres
sujets alors que le sujet principal de
la vidéo c'était vraiment le succès de
la bienveillance et c'est pour ça que
j'ai renommée la vidéo ainsi car
vraiment le point vraiment intéressant
que voulait signer dans la vidéo c'est
suite aux lectures de christian piccini
d'observation selon laquelle est trop
bienveillant c'est en fait quelque chose
qui semble très efficace pour amener des
gens très retranchés dans leurs
convictions à prendre du recul sur leurs
convictions à réfléchir sur leurs
convictions et à chercher à mieux les
justifier voire à les remettre en
question
finalement c'est vraiment ça le
pansement plus intéressant dans la
démarche de piccini c'est que c'est une
marque d'une démarche qui semble
efficace pour amener les gens à mieux
réfléchir à prendre d'autant plus de la
réflexion et ça c'est valable pour à peu
près n'importe quelle sorte de
conviction c'est pas du tout spécifique
watts supprime schiste que les gens
soient retranchées dans leurs
convictions politiques dans leurs
convictions conspirationnistes dans
leurs convictions écologistes ou dans
leurs convictions bayésienne bas parfois
on va tellement loin dans ces choses que
on prend pas forcément suffisamment de
recul et on prend pas forcément compte
toutes les différentes perspectives et
canton ou défi dans un débat ben il nous
arrive très souvent de nous re trancher
dans ses convictions et voire d'aller
plus loin encore dans ces conditions est
la preuve de pitié unis semblait
extrêmement bonnes pour éviter cela
éviter que les gens soient en mode
réactance les années davantage à
réfléchir
ce qui semble extrêmement bénéfique dans
le monde extrêmement complexe dans
lequel on vit même plus généralement le
succès de la bienveillance a finalement
peu à voir avec la radicalisation c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui semble
efficace notamment un des exemples c'est
pour enseigner les mathématiques elle
sans qu un minimum de bienveillance
envers lé 28 d'étudiants chercher à
vouloir son bien et pas uniquement à
lessac et à l'examen c'est indispensable
pour amener les étudiants à mieux
réfléchir et à progresser en
mathématiques en tout cas il me semble
que c'est quelque chose qui s'applique
au delà des de la princesse les
mathématiques
alors ceci dit dans la vidéo présente il
y a une petite visée politique sans en
aller jusqu'à chercher à des radicaliser
certaines certaines sous population avec
certaines convictions piccini lui dit le
dit lui-même
on vit dans un monde qui est de plus en
plus polarisé où il ya de plus en plus
de tensions qui peuvent dégénérer
twitter en particulier n'a vraiment pas
le clash est particulièrement mise en
avant est particulièrement addictif
également et d'après people in i si on
veut stopper des vagues de haine qui
sévissent sur internet et irl il est
indispensable consomme est davantage à
discuter et pour que les discussions se
passent bien il était responsable qu'on
cherche davantage à ressentir de la
compassion il doit bienveillance envers
des personnes qui ont pourtant commis
des à-coups disent des choses on trouve
absolument atroce 205 actions pour tout
ça mais je viens dire que à titre
personnel
ça me fait un peu bizarre de parler de
tout ça parce que je me sens absolument
pas la hauteur je me sens absolument pas
au niveau où étudia de christian piccini
et même de ce que je pense que il faut
que je pense que je devrais avoir dans
un monde idéal donc j'ai énormément de
progrès à faire et ça m'embête beaucoup
de paraître pour quelqu'un qui donne des
leçons c'est bien sûr pas du tout la
posture que j'aimerais avoir si ce que
j'aimerais davantage c'est qu'on
réfléchisse ensemble à comment mieux
mieux débattre que chacun d'entre nous
au réfléchissent quels sont les manières
d'avoir des discussions qui sont plus
productives plus utile pour tout le
monde
plus bénéfique pour tout le monde et
pour la société et en cela la proche de
christian py turini mais également
d'autres des rôles davis ou encore
contrat point tout à part les blancs que
ces deux dernières vidéos toutes ces
approches là me semble relativement
négligées c'est pas salé auquel on pense
en priorité
du coup je trouve ça intéressant de les
mettre beaucoup plus en avant que c'est
le cas
d'autant que elle semble vraiment
également efficace bref ces vidéos c'est
plus pour essayer de présenter les
approches qui me semblent les plus
efficaces pour mieux débattre ce n'est
pas du tout des éléments que je mets en
avant pour essayer de prétendre que je
débats venu que les autres absolument
pas
je vois les principes que je devrais
appliquée mais en pratique c'est super
difficile je n'arrive pas toujours et je
suis très très très loin de l'idéal que
j'essaie de décrire dans ses vidéos
attaquant mieux car ceci étant si je
fais cette vidéo c'est pas uniquement
pour pour présenter les excuses
c'est également pour essayer de
clarifier ce qui n'était pas clair dans
la vidéo précédente pour essayer de
mieux comprendre les idées de piccini et
comme on cherche à mieux les disséquer
voir ce qui marche bien ce qui marche
pas et dans quelle mesure chacun d'entre
nous peut chercher à les appliquer ou au
moins progressé dans leurs applications
première question qui a paru très
souvent en réaction à la vidéo
précédente c'est à ce qu'il faut
débattre avec des nazis ou des gens
qu'ils ont de très extrême c'est un
débat ça c'est une question qui est très
très débattue dans toutes sortes de
milieux
ils s'envoient énormément de notions
psychologique et sociologique qui sont
eux mêmes très complexe donc mesuré bien
l'étendue de mon ignorance et chercher
d'autres informations d'autres
perspectives
pour compléter tout ça alors j'ai essayé
de beaucoup moins fort mais bien sûr à
ce sujet et ce qui en ressort c'est que
déjà si vous vous lancez directement
comme ça peu après à foix dans des
débats avec des gens très retranchés
dans leurs convictions c'est dangereux
que c'est c'est vraiment dangereux et ça
peut paraître beaucoup dans le livre de
piccini tous les gens très radicaliser
ne sont pas bienveillant ne seront pas à
bienveillant par défaut avec vous ils
peuvent être très bienveillant les uns
un verre avec les autres mais pas
forcément avec des gens qui ne sont pas
les leurs et du coup c'est très
important de faire attention déjà pour
commencer à soi même à son à son
bien-être et à sa sécurité
et en plus de ça il est bon de garder en
tête que si vous vous y prenez mal il y
a des chances que vous à graviers la
situation est possible que par exemple
en débattant de mal avec quelqu'un qui
est déjà retranchés dans ses convictions
le fait que vous n'ayez pas des bons
arguments pour défendre votre position
face que l'autre augmente sa créance en
fait qu'il a raison et que l'avis
contraire est un avis très mal informés
et ça c'est particulièrement le cas
présent le cas dans de nombreux domaines
mais c'est notamment le cas des théories
conspirationnistes par exemple la
théorie de la terre plate il vaut mieux
pas engager un débat sur cette théorie
avec quelqu'un qui s'y connaît beaucoup
parce qu'il connaît beaucoup il connaît
beaucoup d'arguments
par exemple en faveur de la terre est
plate et il a également appris beaucoup
de façons de mettre à mal les arguments
naïf en faveur de l'idée que la terre
n'est pas plate donc en engageant un
débat avec ces personnes là surtout si
vous entrez dans un débat d'idées il ya
vraiment un risque que
l'autre personne augmente sacré
lancement d'une croyance erronée donc
débattre avec des personnes travaux
trancher dans leur opinion
ça peut être contre-productif du coup il
vaut mieux bien se préparer avant
d'engager de tels débats je veux me
réfléchira cas peser la balance coûts
bénéfices
ah au fait d'engager un débat avec ces
personnes là ça ça va être d'autant plus
le cas si le débat est public puisque si
le débat est public vous d'influencé pas
uniquement la personne avec qui vous
débattez mais également potentiellement
toutes les personnes qui regardent le
débat et du coup il ya vraiment un
risque que le débat soit en fait très
visible que les mauvais argument gagne
dans le débat c'est quelque chose qui
malheureusement arrivent très souvent
dans des débats très public très
politisé très médiatisé et du coup moins
commencer par des 10 banques privées
avant d'engager des débats publics
ça semble être une bonne chose
encore une chose qui sera plus robuste
le mans bénéfique pour éviter des effets
secondaires indésirables
deuxième question qui a paru souvent c
est ce que il faut exiger des victimes
d'une agression qu'elle éprouve de la
compassion envers les auteurs de
l'agression est très clairement la
priorité dans ce genre de situation
surtout à choses c'est de prendre soin
des personnes qui souffrent en
particulier si de la victime est en fête
exiger quoi que ce soit de quelqu'un
d'autre que cette personne soit
l'agresseur est encore plus saisissant
la victime exiger quelque chose
quelqu'un change de comportement et en
particulier les preuves de la compassion
pour quelqu'un d'autre
c'est quelque chose finalement très
virulent de très très violent en train
d'exiger quelque chose de quelqu'un
d'autre
surtout si on le lui ai dit l'exigent ou
lui dis qu'il faut qu'elle passe quelque
chose ce sera perçu comme quelque chose
de très violents et absolument pas
bienveillant or justement le message la
vidéo présence et de chercher à
développer plus de compassion et
d'empathie pour tout le monde mais ça
c'est un plus mais victime
là où c'est un peu étrange la vidéo
précédente et les idées de piccini c'est
d'encourager la compassion pour aussi
les agresseurs non pas tant parce qu'ils
le méritent mais parce que c'est ce
genre de compassion qui semble plus
efficace pour amener les gens à se
questionner à changer leurs
comportements
après tout il est difficile de changer
les agressions qui ont déjà eu lieu
malheureusement par contre ce qu'on peut
essayer de faire c'est de réduire les
risques que l'agresseur se remettent à
agresser d'autres personnes et l'idée de
piccini c'est que
meilleure stratégie pour y arriver pour
réduire les risques d'agression futur
c'est en fait de commencer par éprouver
de la compassion de comprendre que le
sentir de l'empathie notamment cognitive
comprendre pourquoi est ce que la grèce
eut l agresseur a commis cette agression
qui est une question souvent très très
vaste qui prendra beaucoup de temps à
disséquer mais d'après piccini le faire
et montrer aussi à l'agresseur que on le
fait vraiment pour son bien pas plus
pour qu'il arrête de commettre des
agressions
c'est quelque chose qui semble
extrêmement efficace pour réduire les
actions futures
il faut sur lesquels je pense que ça
vaut le coup d'insister c'est le fait
que faire ce qu'on appelle parfois du
town policing du sila hoening et herman
anglophone n'est pas trop leur
traduction
cette technique consiste à exiger le
calme de certaines personnes ou à les
envahir de questions mais deux questions
virulente de questions qui les pousse
dans leurs retranchements des deux
questions qui risquent de faire sentir
mal plutôt que les aider à développer
leurs idées
ces deux approches sont en fait
extrêmement virulente est absolument pas
bienveillante puisque c'est des
approches qui souvent cherche à piéger
l'autre ces approches sont évidemment
absolument pas ce qui est préconisé par
par christian piccini au contraire c'est
sont des signes de malveillance c'est à
dire vouloir le mal que la personne à
qui ou pas est un point qui est lié à ça
je pense qu'il est intéressant de faire
la distinction entre le calme et la
bienveillance
parce que en fait on peut être très
malveillant en restant calmes parce
qu'on peut par exemple vouloir être
calme juste parce qu'on voit que ça
énerve l'autre dans quels cas c'est un
calme très malveillant être bienveillant
vouloir le bien de l'autre c'est ça se
limite pas du tout à être calme c'est
également un typiquement ressentir et
exprimer de la compassion et
de l'empathie pour ce que subit
l'interlocuteur
d'autres questions qui a paru souvent c
est ce que la méthode de piccini peut
être vu comme de la manipulation est ce
que ça ne serait pas finalement une
forme
une façon pour manipuler l'interlocuteur
et l'année à croire ce qu'on veut qu'il
croit le mot manipulation est
extrêmement connoté je pense que c'est
important de faire attention aux mots
qui sont très connoté qui ont un rapport
flou sur connotation assez important ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est une
stratégie pour pouvoir c'est à dire que
on peut le présenter comme si vous votre
but est de convaincre aucun méthode
punissant particulièrement efficace et
vous rappelle t 2 p tu n'es ça commence
par aider l'autre vouloir le bien de
l'autre chercher à résoudre ces
problèmes donc on peut voir ça comme une
stratégie efficace pour convaincre de
façon aussi intéressante
c'est une stratégie qui aura pour but
instrumentale et du coup pour but d' un
moment le bien de l'autre
donc c'est une stratégie qui est
également extrêmement bienveillante et
pas bienveillante dans un sens signaler
le fait qu'on veut le bien de l'autre
d'enghien veillant dans le sens où on
veut vraiment le bien de l'autre parce
qu'il faut dépasser le bus le
signalement de la vertu le signalement
du fait qu'on veuille et des autres et
être beaucoup plus activement dans une
véritable aide écoute de l'autre pour
que la stratégie de piccini devient
efficace et bon on peut essayer d'autres
et ses talents d'accord notre contre
nous ne sommes pas des très bons acteurs
surtout c'est difficile de garder un
personnage pendant plusieurs heures
longues discussions sur tous ces
discussions français a duré des heures
ce qui marche pour que ça marche
vraiment meilleure stratégie ça semble
vraiment de ressentir de la compassion
et de l'empathie de vraiment vouloir le
bien de l'autre et voir le bien de
l'autre il me semble que c'est quelque
chose de vraiment très très très
souhaitable très désirable d'un point de
vue normatif
bon bien sûr ça c'est ma vie normatif
saas et des bas mais il me semble que la
plupart d'entre nous on est prêt à dire
que si l'autre va mieux c'est pas
forcément si mal en général sauf s'ils
ont vraiment des tests l'autre et on le
veut son mal mais dans ce cas on n'est
pas bien fait alors de façon très lié à
cela une autre question qui est apparu
souvent c'est à ce que compatir avec
l'agresseur s'est du coup l'excusé est
ce qu'être bienveillant envers quelqu'un
c'est forcément dire que c'est une perte
si cette personne est une personne bien
ratenon bienveillance et vouloir le bien
ducatel que veulent utilise le mot
bienveillant signifie vouloir le bien de
l'autre mais ça ne veut pas dire que
l'autre est bien distinction importante
à faire et en particulier on peut être
très bienveillants car piccioni arrive à
être très bienveillants envers des gens
dont les actions sont des actions que
pitié ni profit sierre atroce et façon
intéressante
il n'est en fait pas incompatible de
vouloir le bien de l'autre tout en
voulant qu'il soit puni tout en voulant
que ils subissent quelque chose qui lui
permettent de se souvenir de l'agression
qu'il a fait par exemple et que c'était
mal et que dans le futur il ne commettra
plus ce genre de choses parce que on
peut se dire que pour son bien c'est
aussi une bonne chose qui qu'ils
arrêtent ce genre d'agressions qui
cherchent davantage à s'améliorer d'au
moins un point de vue
morales et épistémique tout ça bien sûr
ça à voir avec le rôle qu'est la justice
dans nos sociétés mais également à titre
individuel et il arrive en effet très
souvent que par exemple des parents ou
des enseignants punissent des élèves
tout en voulant leur bien ça me permet
de faire une autre clarification sur le
mot bienveillance tout cas si on prend
littéralement vouloir le bien de l'autre
ça ne veut pas dire être bisounours
je pense que c'est une analogie qui est
souvent faite est qui et qui me semble
très anciennement problématique puisque
typiquement on a tendance à penser que
le bisounours pense que tout le monde
est gentil
alors c'est pas c'est pas le cas en tout
cas beaucoup de gens commettent et des
choses atroces et vont probablement
continuer à commettre des choses atroces
surtout si nous n'intervenons pas ça
c'est quelque chose de descriptifs c'est
quelque chose qui fait partie de la
prédiction et pour avoir des débats
constructifs
il est très important de prendre toute
la mesure de cette dimension descriptive
prédictive bien savoir rester gens sont
amenés à faire et si on se dit
bisounours
il ya un risque à ce qu'on se ferme un
petit peu les yeux et qu'on oublie
[Musique]
et par exemple les atrocités commises
par d'autres mais également les
atrocités que d'autres vont probablement
connaître surtout en l'absence
d'intervention
je pense qu'un meilleur exemple de ce qu
être bienveillant des bas c'est
l'exemple de questions et piccini et
d'autres qui sont des gens qui sont
vraiment bien veillant surtout pete unis
on sent qu'il veut le bien des personnes
des personnes qui cherchent à des
radicaliser mais il n'est pas non plus
naïf ou il pense pas que tout le monde
est gentil par défaut et notamment
extrêmement prudents vis-à-vis des
risques que posent toutes les personnes
dangereuses
on a commencé par exemple beaucoup de
dérives de oued supprima schiste qui
sont auteurs de plus d'attentats par
exemple aux états unis que que deux
terroristes islamistes
en cela le terrorisme des voix de
secouriste est sans doute bien plus
préoccupant que celui des islamistes
radicaux
or une autre question qui est très
récurrentes et pas seulement par rapport
à la vidéo précédente mais très
récurrentes vis-à-vis de la claque des
mains est au mieux
c'est la question de savoir à ce que la
violence c'est mal ben j'ai envie de
dire en soi la virulence si et surtout
sénat fait que personne n est pas
nécessairement mal si si la violence
envers quelqu'un ça va voir au moins un
petit coup au moral ou moins le bien
être des personnes victimes de la
virulence mais parfois ça fait comme on
la vit punir c'est utile et du coup la
violence c'est pas systématiquement mal
par défaut ça dépend de lui la balance
coûts bénéfices entre les avantages
d'être virulentes et les effets
secondaires néfastes de cette virulence
par opposition à une stratégie basée sur
la bienveillance telle que celle de
peter ring
il ya des cas où il semble que cette
violence est vraiment utile ou rappeler
les personnes à l'ordre de façon parfois
un peu brusque permet vraiment un
changement de comportement mais il me
semble aussi que les conditions dans
lesquelles la violence est vraiment
efficace et utile sont beaucoup plus
faibles que l'ensemble des cas où on va
penser instinctivement à utiliser de la
virulence et la raison pour cela c'est
que la violence est souvent très
instinctive et a du coup on a tendance à
sauter des étapes de réflexion et à
arrêter une réflexion une fois qu'on est
devenu un virulent et en particulier
dans ce genre de cas ça peut être
beaucoup plus difficile de prendre le
temps de réflexion pour mesurer les
effets secondaires de notre virulence
qui en fait semble loin d'être
négligeable une autre chose qui est
difficile lorsqu'on commence à être
violence et d'envisager le
contrefactuelle c'est à dire ce qui se
passerait si nous on avait une réaction
beaucoup plus bienveillante toujours une
réaction marquée mais plus bienveillante
et le livre de piccini est vraiment
fascinant en tant que tel puisque il
nous offre un peu une idée de ce qu'on
pourrait atteindre 6 ont adopté cette
seconde stratégie plutôt que la
stratégie qu'il vient
immédiatement à l'esprit bref la
virulence surtout la virulence
instinctive
c'est quelque chose qui me semblent
sous-optimale parfois même très
indésirable car ça a des effets
secondaires potentiellement énorme et
que donc la virulence ça peut être
largement une solution si on a bien
réfléchi on a bien pesé fait la balance
coûts-bénéfices aimerait bien peser le
pour et le contre on s'est dit en effet
la être violent ça sera très efficace
mais si c'est pas le cas je pense que
c'est utile de se dire davantage que par
défaut la virulence c'est pas la bonne
stratégie
parce que ça va freiner notre instinct
et ça va nous aider à passer beaucoup
plus en mode réflexif et ensuite on peut
consacre dans ce coup bénéfices et c'est
d'être aussi bienveillants pour qu'on
était un peu de données pour savoir
quelle sauce quel est l'impact d'être
bienveillant au quotidien je pense que
c'est quelque chose que j'ai pu mesurer
seulement au cours des dernières années
parce que ça ne fait plus que quelques
années que je réfléchisse à acheter que
va-t-on et que je cherche et
bienveillant et moi j'ai des données
parfois qu ils me surprennent sur
l'efficacité de la bienveillance c'est
arrivé plusieurs fois de rejoindre de
m'excuser sur twitter et d'être surpris
de la réaction des autres une fois que
je me suis excusé c'est ça peut être
très très déroutant et en tout cas c'est
des choses à prendre en compte quand on
cherche à estimer s'il vaut mieux être
virulent ou
s'il vaut mieux prendre de temps de
réflexion et chercher à être plus plus
bienveillants éthiquement à l'écouté et
on va faire l'effort de ressentir de la
compassion pour l'autre
enfin une dernière question qu'on m'a
remonté c'est ce qu'on peut résoudre
tous avec le débat et la discussion est
ce que vraiment c'est la solution à
chaque fois et là j'ai envie de dire non
parfois la discussion le débat même très
très long bias et un coup ça prend du
temps de débattre vraiment prendre le
temps de les battre en écoutant ça ça
prend beaucoup beaucoup de temps donc
clairement ce n'est pas une solution qui
ferait adopter tout le temps et parfois
même l'histoire de la philosophie
montrent que même sur des questions
débattues pendant des siècles par des
gens très brillants et souvent très
bienveillant bas on peut être sûr une
impasse et ne pas avoir de consensus
il faut l'anticiper je pense que c'est
très important de dire que la discussion
n'aboutira pas tout le temps et suffit
pas de délibérer pour que tout aille
bien
et dans ce genre de situation bah
il ya plusieurs solutions qui
historiques qui ont été utilisés l'une
d'elles c'est utiliser la force la force
avec la loi du plus fort c'est ici les
plus forts sont du bon côté plaisir que
et s'ils sont nettement du moment côté
on peut dire que c'est peut-être une
bonne chose
il fonctionne nettement du bon côté
parce qu'il ya un coût entrée en guerre
notamment
bref la force faut vraiment être sûr de
soi que c'est la bonne solution est sûr
que les effets secondaires d'utiliser à
force ne sont pas trop dévastateur pour
pour se dire que c'est la bonne solution
et surtout faut comparer ça à d'autres
solutions contractuelles et sauf qu'il
ya pas mal d'autres solutions beaucoup
plus
paisible beaucoup moins violentes qui
ont beaucoup moins d'effets secondaires
néfastes comme par exemple le fait
d'utiliser des scrutins et c'est lorsque
des choses qui m'a beaucoup fasciné dans
ma propre recherche quand j'ai essayé
par exemple ce que tu 1 de condorcet
randomisés c'est le fait de menton que
utiliser de telles méthodes
c'était aussi une façon de résoudre le
problème de la délibération qui ne
termine jamais alors ceci dit il faut
absolument pas voir les copains de
condorcet endo miser comme une solution
à tout fait lorsque ton orsay randomisés
mais heureusement très restreint
puisqu'il ne permet de faire des votes
que lorsque le nombre d'alternatives est
faible or si on prend les points de
complexes que comme que faire par
rapport aux changements climatiques
voyez pas il n'y a pas trois solutions
il faut choisir une parmi 3 nombre
combiné au real de solutions possibles
d'investissements possibles va y ait un
nombre énorme de décisions à prendre
et pourtant toutes ces décisions ce que
tu ne veux pas fonctionné donc il va
falloir des méthodes beaucoup combiné
parfois à certaines méthodes plus
délibérative parfois certaines méthodes
qui sont plus des scrutins ou avoir des
formes de scrutin plus sophistiqués dont
on parle notamment dans le livre le
fabuleux chantier qui serait pas vieux
sur un petit nombre de d'alternative
mais sur des objets combinatoire you non
c'est la recherche encore très
fascinante numéro 1 qui pas du tout
mature encore à l'heure où je vous parle
il ya beaucoup progressé avec le
fantastique à l'article wild eyes
bref il ya encore beaucoup de réflexion
à faire sur plein d'aspects
psychologiques sociologiques
algorithmique mathématiques pour essayer
de nous amener à prendre les meilleures
décisions ensemble et parfois ses
meilleures décisions ne n'incluront pas
le fait d'avoir des débats qui lui aura
six heures par jour pendant un an alors
une chose que j'aimerais ajouter par
rapport à tout ça c'est cette idée selon
laquelle le compromis et
chose au milieu et forcément la bonne
issue d'un débat non par exemple sur des
questions de maths c'est une personne
pense que un plus un égale à 1 2 et
l'autre en secret plus un égale à 3 le
compromis entre leurs deux solutions est
du coup en plus intégrale à 2,5 et
j'imagine ce serait sans doute pas la
bonne solution atteindre donc non le
fait d'être au milieu n'est pas
forcément la bonne issue d'une
discussion notamment sa discussion et
constructive
on peut imaginer que certains certaines
positions défendues dans le débat vont
peser beaucoup plus que d'autres défis
de positions défendues dans le débat et
que du coup après délibération peut-être
que les gens se mettront d'accord sur
quelque chose qui était en fait très
proche de ce que l'une des personnes
dont le débat a initialement proposé
mais peut-être que de façon plus
intéressante
je pense qu'il est bon de se cuisiner
que les 10 les débats ne sont
généralement pas unidimensionnel ce
qu'on se demande un plus un égale à
combien on se demande pas juste est-ce
que c'est égal à deux ou à trois et à
quel nombre à entre les deux souvent il
ya beaucoup plus de subtilité que ça
parle on peut se demander dans quel
corps des nombres
en compte base 2 on peut avoir des
réponses plus intéressante peut avoir
plus de subtilité en tout cas les
subtilités sont à va être très
intéressante
et pour ça je vous renvoie l'excellente
vidéo de syllabus kyi et porte sur sa la
plus grande claque de vulgarisation qui
a reçu viviane qui est vidéo que je
recommande absolument où la question
c'était sur la dangerosité des ondes et
en particulier un prof avait introduit
une conférence en posant la question est
ce que les ondes sont dangereuses et la
question c'est pas oui non 50%
la réponse vraiment intéressante c'est
oui il ya des zones dangereuses mais non
toutes les ondes ne sont pas dangereuses
et comprendre qu'elles sont dangereuses
dans quelles circonstances
c'est un problème en tant que tel et les
subtilités à sont absolument critique
puisque ça va permettre mieux répondre à
cette question va permettre de concevoir
par exemple des compteurs linky ou des
antennes 5g puce sécurisée qui n'ont pas
de problèmes de santé et de recherche
sur ça et beaucoup de normes direction
mise en place et voir les gens ont été
surpris à te rends compte que les trucs
les plus dangereux que d'autres mieux
comprendre toutes ces subtilités
c'est absolument critique pour naviguer
dans notre quotidien
c'est dire que va teaser un four à micro
ondes
en fait c'est pas ce pas dangereux que
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup moins dangereux tant de choses
d'autre qu'on fait au quotidien juste
marcher au bord d'une route
mais à l'envers ce être exposé au soleil
quand je suis là sans crème solaire
c'est recevoir des ondes qui elles
peuvent potentiellement être très
néfaste est très dangereuse
bref c'est arrivé jusqu'ici où elle vous
remercie de votre attention de gros
effort d'écouté de l'autre parent merci
beaucoup
j'espère que cette longue discussion a
permis de clarifier certains points à 1
er chose pour conclure c'est fait que
dans la vidéo précédente j'ai omis pas
mal de choses je pense qu'on a fait à la
vidéo précédente était très améliorable
ya beaucoup de choses que j'ai mal fait
me me dire ça augmente aussi à ma chérie
tu es interprétative et quand ils ont
envie d'être plus charitable
interprétative mans vers ceux qui ont
des vidéos plus courtes ou qui écrivent
des tweets plus court parce que quand on
écrit un truc cours bah forcément on va
au maître des choses on va dire des
choses avec des sous-entendus qui risque
d'être mal interprétées je pense que
c'est utile de chercher à davantage leur
écoute de les aider à mieux exprimer
leurs idées voire de les aider à mieux
exprimer leurs idées et ensuite de les
aider à résoudre les problèmes qui
veulent résoudre avant peut-être ensuite
de chercher à leur montrer comment ils
peuvent progresser dans leur propre
démarche
sur ce je vous remercie à nouveau de
votre attention je vous fais des gros
bisous et j'espère que ça si vous
amènera à réfléchir davantage aux idéaux
pitié ni voir à chercher à les appliquer
vous même temps les repas de famille par
exemple ou sur twitter